In this lecture, we
introduce linear regression
a simple but very powerful
method to analyze data
and make predictions
and apply it
in a very unexpected
context-- predicting
the quality of wines.
Bordeaux is a region in France
popular for producing wine.
While this wine
has been produced
in much the same way
for hundreds of years,
there are differences
in price and quality
from year to year that are
sometimes very significant.
Bordeaux wines are
widely believed
to taste better
when they are order,
so there's an incentive
to store young wines
until they are mature.
The main problem is that
it is hard to determine
the quality of the wine when it
is so young just by tasting it,
since the taste will change so
significantly by the time it
will actually be consumed.
This is why wine tasters
and experts are helpful.
They taste the wines
and then predict
which ones will be
the best wines later.
The question we'll
address in this lecture--
can analytics model
this process better
and make stronger predictions?
On March 4, 1990,
the New York Times
announced that Princeton
economics professor Orley
Ashenfelter can predict the
quality of Bordeaux wine
without tasting a single drop.
Ashenfelter's
predictions have nothing
to do with assessing
the aroma of the wine,
looking at the legs, or
declaring that the wine tastes
citrusy, oaky, or nutty.
They are the results of
a mathematical model.
Ashenfelter used a method
called linear regression.
The methods predicts an outcome
variable or dependent variable.
And in doing so, it
uses a set of what
is called independent variables.
For the dependent
variable, Ashenfelter
chose a typical price in
1990-1991 for Bordeaux wine
in an auction.
This approximates quality.
As independent
variables, he used
age of the wine-- so the older
wines are more expensive--
and weather-related
information, specifically
the average growing season
temperature, the harvest
rain, and winter rain.
In these figures,
we depict the data
during the period
from 1952 to 1978.
There are four
independent variables--
the age of the wine, the average
growing season temperature,
the harvest rain,
and winter rain.
And on the vertical axis,
you observe the logarithm
of the price, the
realization in an auction.
So these are the primitive
data that Ashenfelter used.
So Ashenfelter believed
that his predictions
are more accurate than
those of the world's
most influential wine critic.
His name is Robert Parker.
In response, Parker
called Ashenfelter
to be "an absolute total
sham," and he adds that,
"rather like a movie critic
who never goes to see the movie
but tells you how
good it is based
on the actors and the director."